I always believe in upgrading myself
upskilling not only helped me with the
knowledge boost but also help me to
reach New Heights in my professional
career I am currently the chief
technology officer at O3 Technology
Solutions New York USA we serve our
clients in the banking finance and
incident sector hi I am radhakrishna
Puri I have 25 plus years of experience
in the information technology domain I
have worked for large organizations like
IBM India Tata infotech Sunrise
assistance Gulf business machines in
Dubai after working for almost 14 years
in Dubai at GBM I wanted to make a
career change and to do that I had to
improve my portfolio that's why I chose
to upskill myself and decided to take
professional certification program in
blockchain from IIT Concord offered by
simply learn after completing the course
I was able to make a complete Paradigm
ship to my career to grow to the
position of city world combinational
skill set like artificial intelligence
machine learning cloud computing and
especially blockchain is the reason the
management thought and the right fit to
the position of CTO the course helped me
understand the end-to-end architecture
side of it which gave me ample knowledge
about programming in solidity and
understanding the different blockchain
platforms Technologies and functions
like cryptography cryptocurrency
benefits tokenization decentral finance
and decentralized applications after
completing the course
I'm definitely more confident about
connecting with clients understanding
the problem statements and coming out
with Solutions I am a fitness Enthusiast
when I was in Dubai I got into fitness
my last 20 kgs of weight in four years
what my fitness journey taught me was
to achieve something in life you need to
keep pushing and improving yourself the
funny thing is that I am a foodie too
I love to eat good food so basically I
exercise to eat good food and still stay
in shape the same philosophy applies in
everyone's professional career as well
one needs to keep upskilling and
continuously try improving their skill
to grow as a professional I strongly
recommend gaining new skills regularly
to stay relevant and to achieve your
career goals